foreign
[Music]
what's good everybody dailyvee is just
like super fun it's back I know a lot of
you are enjoying it I'll try to give you
everything that's Brewing I'm working
hard on V friends and vaynerx and
there's a lot going on and uh and I hope
you learned something through the
osmosis of the show and so enjoy
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented sunshine
[Music]
foreign
founder versus second or multi-time
founder when I'm feeling good about life
I can get excited about first time
founder and all the best companies I
love are first time Founders so I'm like
[__] here it is right when I'm a hair
less excited about it boy show me
someone who's actually executed it's a
lot more fun founder with more technical
skills or founder with more business
skills number two and not even close by
the way some people have both like zucks
really had both by the way the reason I
invested in Facebook was number two look
I think it depends on the challenge
brother like if we're doing a
direct-to-consumer brand that really
wants to take market share from Procter
and Gamble it's definitely going to be
business like if we're gonna go deep
deep AI I'll go with the technical right
and so to the point of where web3 is and
the point of where AI is I can wrap my
head more for the first time in a decade
around a technical founder because some
of the challenges in front of us are
more technical worked at Fang or did not
work at Fang you show me somebody who
isn't the number one or two at one of
those companies and is a number five
seven thirteen nineteen and I'll show
you the 1990 Bulls besides Michael
Jordan I'm petrified of the number 11
from Netflix I actually don't invest in
anyone who's number 13 at Apple because
I view them as BJ Armstrong or Horace
Grant for everybody who doesn't follow
90s basketball those were teammates of
Michael Jordan when he won all the
Championships then they went to other
teams and signed huge contracts and
contributed absolutely nothing I mean
Horace granted a little something but
fair enough family members as Founders
if you in this room find yourself to be
extremely emotionally intelligent you're
like [__] this is what I have I have
great intuition in EQ then all day long
you invest in family businesses because
you can snip it to 50 or 60 or 70
percent hit of it is it gonna work if
you find yourself unfortunately not
having that capability and you're more
the black and white engineer other
aspects you should stay as far away from
family businesses as humanly possible
co-ceos versus a single CEO two Cooks in
the kitchen is the stupidest thing of
all time probably out of all the
questions so far the thing that I'm most
emphatic about anybody who signs up to
be
stinks you know I'm sure there's
unlimited stories of successful co-ceos
that have worked it's just not my cup of
tea and it's just not how I see what a
CEO has to be to really win it's funny
back to the cousin of that I'm not
scared off by six co-founders but I just
need to know who the number one is who's
the 1A you can all be one piece you can
have a thousand of them honestly you
really could that's just Optics back to
emotional intelligence I would argue
sometimes a business I'd fall in love
with is the 1A realized for what she or
he's trying to achieve that she wanted
to give four people the co-founding
title because she's got this retention
strategy over the next half decade so
that doesn't bother me at all the actual
Co scares me to no end comes from money
or is starting from the dirt I used to
be simplistic on this one where I liked
the person from the dirt more because I
always felt that if you were fed it's
hard to be hungry so that used to be my
answer now 25 of the time I can get
excited about comes from money because
I've seen too much patterns of like it's
a chip on shoulder it's actually a
motivator right like in Reverse they
actually have a ton of admiration for
people that build monsters that came
from really good stitches like that's
[__] hard so I'm like 25 in that
world I'm now 50 50 on the comes from
nothing because unfortunately the people
that come from nothing there is a bad
version where the insecurity is so deep
it is driving them but it often can die
in the last inning or in the fourth
quarter and that's scary that the
insecurity eats them up it's a little
bit like dark like Darth Vader should
have actually won but did it you know
because I was so fortunate that I had
the greatest mother of all time and so I
was built on self-esteem and I came from
nothing it worked super well but over
time I'm like oh wait a minute a lot of
people weren't as fortunate as I was
with that and it's their insecurity
that's their driving force and look the
reality is is that it's not sustainable
I don't think about things about
tomorrow I keep an eye on things about
tomorrow I don't focus on yesterday I
try to change a lot of my friends and
contemporaries and clients to get a way
of being religious about yesterday so
I'm a champion of today and metaverse is
not here today in my opinion but I'm
keeping a heavy eye on it no different
back to transition of AI I looked at so
many AI startups three four five years
ago and almost all of them were API or
fake AI they weren't AI now are you
kidding me with this Jasper this and
your chat GPD this and today I saw a
headline about Google Music something
that like boy oh boy oh boy oh boy are
we here well now this becomes a
conversation about today so I think AI
is going to have a very nice rise here
it's gonna be interesting to watch I
consider it part of web 3 in some ways
you know I think all these new
technologies will probably get
categorized that way and I'm excited
about it but as far as the metaverse I
really struggle seeing it not being a
big part of life I just don't know if
that's seven years from now three or 22.
so I've always keeping a side eye on it
while I focus on what to execute on
today
[Music]
we need to find the next creative
framework that everyone copies that's
the new Mission at hand got it like
remember the Instagram egg make that egg
Let It crack and let me come out of it
and start my video right because that's
a historically known got it start using
color schemes that haven't been used
before palettes angles like there was a
time where like I posted something on
purpose upside down that seems like you
messed up I was like no I'm trying to
like that might be actually the answer
thank you
going to see Lebron in the garden with
my main man Nima look at the kicks yeah
rare robot rare robot
see you later
[Music]